what russia might do next has hung heavy
here but the city of london may be
breathing a small sigh of relief
sanctions for now a first step and not
sweeping
the key targets are five russian banks
but none are the biggest or most
important bill browder is a former major
investor in russia this he says lacks
teeth if the uk really wants to make an
impact
the british government should freeze the
assets of the top 50 oligarchs who look
after putin's money and possibly go
after spare bank and btb bank which are
the two largest banks in russia
the the the banks that were sanctioned
today um one of them has already been
sanctioned the other four i've never
heard of
it's thought there's more russian money
in london than any other city in the
world mansions of the mega rich and much
else besides it means there is leverage
here this time it's being wielded on
three individuals gennady timchenko
boris rottenberg a judo partner of
putin's no less and his nephew igor
but all have been sanctioned before by
america their assets here will be frozen
it may not bite much
anybody who is really anybody and knew
that these sanctions were coming
probably dealt with this a long time ago
um so you know we would expect that
there probably isn't a lot of money
being held in the uk in particular it's
probably been moved offshore ages ago
and impact may also be limited because
russia has been preparing its gold
reserves alone have tripled since 2014.
there are other much more serious
sanction options things like banning
trade with russian multinationals or
blocking exports of certain products to
russia and then that's what's being
described as the nuclear option banning
russian banks from a system called swift
it's an international banking messaging
platform it would essentially disrupt
almost all of russia's global payments
these measures would all hurt russia but
they would also hurt british business
and investors perhaps part of the reason
they're being held back
and nowhere is that more true than with
energy
russia supplies 47 of all europe's gas
blocking it altogether perhaps too much
to consider
but others have gone further the eu will
hit 27 different people and entities the
us two banks and a ban on russian bonds
fighting for peace does have a price and
it'll be paid by more than just putin
helen and smith sky news